Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
it's a beautiful sunny day here in Los
Angeles but I'm gonna head into this
convention center this cold Convention
Center to check out what Sony Microsoft
Nintendo going to have us playing for
the next couple of years it's a trade
only event but I've got my press pass so
let's go ahead inside yes we've got our
man in Los Angeles for the biggest video
gaming convention in the world stay
tuned for in-depth insights into all
things III as well as the biggest
stories coming out of LA we've got a
roundup of the rest of the week tech
news and of course with III comes new
games our review has done the hard work
and narrowed them down for us it's that
time of year again attracting nearly
50,000 gamers developers and journalists
from all over the world Electronic
Entertainment Expo otherwise known as e3
no not here in London over in LA has
been taking place this people and it's a
very special year for the event its
twenty years old and as a reminder of
just how much the gaming industry has
changed come along to this retro arcade
through the heart of gaming in London
for a trip down memory lane while we
play on some of these classics and
before we catch up with our man in LA
here's Angela with a roundup of e3's
best fits our first game tonight has
been long anticipated by the gaming
community sony used this year's event to
surprise its audience announcing the
release of the Last Guardian the game
has been in development for over five
years with fans giving up hope on it
ever coming out and although the release
date was a little vague the company says
it's coming to PlayStation 4 next year
in the battle to be the best rival
Microsoft use the event to show off a
new trailer of halo 5 guardians for Xbox
one showcasing it's for
player cooperative mode the game will
also feature at least one Hollywood
talent and making something old new
again microsoft also introduced
backwards compatibility meaning older
xbox 360 games will be playable on the
Xbox one console this year continuing
the annual showdown the console giants
outline plans for virtual reality
Microsoft talked about its relationship
with oculus VR and announced a new
version of Minecraft specifically for
its hollow lens headset let's take our
experience off the wall and then put it
on the table over here Sony didn't
elaborate too much on its project
Morpheus other than it still exists and
a variety of different games are being
developed for it other announcements
came thick and fast classic Nintendo
games dominated the Japanese firms
presentation with new versions of zelda
mario and starfox being released gaming
studio Beth de announced the release
date for fallout 4 in November a Final
Fantasy 7 remake was also revealed
giving in to almost two decades of fan
demands the role-playing game doesn't
have a release date but it will launch
first on PlayStation 4 Mass Effect
Andromeda was introduced as the next
installment of Bioware's epic space
opera
and a new call of duty black ops 3 is
also out in Alton
Electronic Arts added to the end via
competition with star wars battlefront
going to do it bigger and we will settle
for nothing less than an ID bag I gave
back the Ubisoft all eyes are on the new
southpark game which is a sequel to last
year's the stick of truth the
announcement came as a surprise after
the show creators veiled that they would
never make another video game again 15
have to be three Angela Barnes Sky News
so what's the expert opinion on all
those figured out lives over in la guy
Kaka games and technology expert is
there for us any fantastic tummy
PlayStation really have the big
announcements that gamers really care
about they've got games like no man's
sky The Last Guardian even far Fantasy 7
remake coming to their console so for me
the winner of this e3 is probably
PlayStation so virtual reality is one of
the big things in the gaming space right
now next year we're actually going to
see these headsets come out on the
market this is Sony's project Morpheus
which is going to work with the
PlayStation 4 it's going to be coming
out around the middle of next year we
don't know price details yet but so we
think around 200 250 pounds and it's
really a big leap in how games work if
you look at the screen over here you can
see you're viewing this world through
another flat window but when you put on
a VR headset wherever you're looking and
wherever you move the the game world is
you feel like you're right in there it's
a very very immersive experience for me
the sonic Sony project Morpheus has
probably got the most potential because
it works for PlayStation 4 and so many
people have a PlayStation 4 console for
me I can't wait to get my hands on it
there are three key things for me at
microsoft booth here at e3 2015 one is
core franchises that game is really care
about rise of the Tomb Raider gears of
war Forza halo 5 these are all coming to
xbox within the next year then there's
the technical stuff that they're doing
they've got hollow lens which is a new
VR headset they're going to allow you to
play games that's still in development
and they're also going to later play pc
mods on fallout 4 one of the biggest
games of the year some really
interesting technical stuff now can you
remember which year
game was released it's the first one
ever to feature Super Mario but in those
days he was just known as jump map
before something shiny and new is Ross
in LA with his favorite releases to come
out of e3 oh and this was 1981 by the
way first up it's fallout 4 now this
franchise has been around for a long
long time and has been teased just a
couple of weeks prior to e3 and now we
know a lot more about it it's this huge
open world you can play as either a male
or a female character there is a lovely
little dog that you now has a companion
to take you through the wastelands and
it all will come together in Boston but
it is coming out this year which is
great news for fallout fans and anybody
that's new to the franchise this has got
a going to be a hit and I cannot wait
for this game so this is definitely one
of my games of e3 next up is Rainbow six
siege from Ubisoft this game again is a
franchise that I cannot wait for it
offers five versus five competitive
gameplay but we've also seen from this
year's e3 is the five player co-op mode
where you are going up against AI
controlled opponents to basically take
down a siege where there's either a bomb
or hostage and it's all about how
tactically you insert yourself into that
scenario so all in all Rainbow six siege
from Ubisoft is going to be an
absolutely amazing game out this year
the call of duty franchise is back and
this year it is call of duty black ops 3
yes one of the most anticipated
franchises of Call of Duty is back and
it's going to be bigger and better than
ever we've seen not just a single player
but multiplayer at this year's e3 single
player offering four player co-op for
the first time in the campaign loads of
new abilities loads of new weapons what
we saw from it there was a load of
action going on there's mex slightly
futuristic but just a huge amount of
action as you would expect from call of
duty black ops 2 was such a phenomenon
for the quality franchise everybody
cannot wait now for black ops 3 and we
haven't got that long to wait because
again it's out in November of 2015 so
they all my top games releasing in 2015
but we've seen so many other games
coming out
2016 with uncharted 4 gears for the
division the list can go on and on and I
cannot wait not just for the rest of
this year but what we're going to see in
2016 and beyond now away from e3 and
away from Mario here's a roundup of some
of this week's other tech news NASA gave
us a glimpse of life onboard the
International Space Station with a new
clarity this week a 4k Ultra
high-definition video is released
showing views of planet Earth as well as
commander terry virts eating a space
burger the footage was shot before he
and two of his fellow astronauts
returned to Earth last week it's hoped
the improved resolution video will mean
researchers can get new insights into
experiments onboard the ISS a New York
start up behind headphones that let you
control sounds around you has now
brought the system to the UK via
Kickstarter the here earbuds can
suppress or enhance noises in your
environment so you could turn down the
sound of a loud engine or boost the base
inside a nightclub the wearable smashed
a crowdfunding target of $250,000 within
two days when it launched in the u.s.
London Mayor Boris Johnson was learning
to code this week he joined secondary
school pupils at a session in Camden to
mark the launch of London technology
week research shows London has cemented
its place as the most important tech hub
in Europe its forecast to boost the
city's economy by 18 billion pounds this
year without their for this week I'm off
to get in the groove 2006 style see you
next time bye bye
gotcha ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News